now next EV has a big challenge ahead
how will next EV stand out it's actually
good that so many companies are getting
into the electric vehicle market you
know this is an old industry no the auto
industry is almost 100 years old and so
i think it's a it's a sign that there is
a transition going to happen and you
know you probably saw it see yes there
was a lot of talk about auto it's
unusual for other companies to be
talking about innovation and development
at a consumer electronics show it sort
of reminds me ten years ago how cell
phone companies were shocking at the
Consumer Electronics Show so that
actually tells me that my instincts
about what is the change that's going to
happen in the outer space is probably
clued in the right direction right some
companies are focused on autonomous
driving completely something some
companies are focused on purely creating
an EV that's a high-performance vehicle
our differentiation is creating a
vehicle that will be more affordable not
just super expensive for a certain class
of people that can own it are you going
to work on autonomous driving features
will you know next EV and self-driving
cars we will but that's not the that's
not the central pieces to what we want
to build the model s does have
autonomous driving features what do you
think of them yeah it's good i think it
the autopilot you mean i think that's
that's a great feature to have again you
know my own belief is that some of these
advanced features over time will become
you know standard right like a few years
ago abs and remote door entry were you
know world or all the new stuff but now
most cars have that so it's not really
about one feature or one technology but
how do you optimize the experience
around the car you know the car should
know who you are what your preferences I
it should know that I prefer to take 280
here and not 101 because every time i
drive from where i live to san francisco
that's the freeway i take i shouldn't
have to punch this in it should know
this and it should learn this so this is
all the thinking from the mobile
internet space right so that's what we
mean by optimizing big so how do you so
first of all like how do you see the
market for self-driving car is playing
out you know when when is this
mainstream will my kids never have to
drive themselves
I think it will be here sooner than we
think there's a dowel rod of regulation
battles that companies are fighting but
we'll fight them and we'll get there I
think full autonomous driving I think
you know your kids will probably see
that